[Music]
welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
stead I am mark Minardi welcome ladies
and gentlemen we are in Hollywood
California at the scum and villainy
Cantina right here on Hollywood
Boulevard put your hands he goes to the
folks watching and listening at home
know that you were real
this is the last time we get to do this
for a minute I'm sure we'll do it like
once or twice before the end of the year
come December or something like that but
I head out fairly soon and start going
back to work as filmmakers when I'm not
podcasting sometimes I make movies if
you believe that or not so we're taking
this movie we made called Jay and Silent
Bob a reboot tour kicks off October 19th
and in New Jersey of course fittingly
and there are 62 dates the first half of
the tour breaks right before Christmas
and so I imagine we'll do a couple more
of these for the end of the year okay
and then we head back out on the road
for like two more months and stuff tour
is that doing incredibly well so thank
you to anyone in this room and at home
who bought tickets man because we've
been at in shows like crazy and Stefon
suits and I look forward to to going out
on the road like Jordan Jason's wife
Jordan runs our company and she's like I
feel so bad like all these dates and I
was like I don't like I look forward to
this man like I'm gonna watch that movie
like every time and it's not just 62
screenings at six to date sometimes
there's three screenings a day and so
I'm gonna be watching it with the most
receptive [ __ ] audience to that [ __ ]
on the planet it's not like I'm showing
it cold to a bunch of people who are
like well I was either gonna see this or
the Joker like there are people who are
like I've been waiting to see this my
whole [ __ ] life here's my kid his
name is Brody you know and so
I'm gonna enjoy every single screening
of the movie I can't wait to go out
there and stuff but it's gonna shut us
down for a little while me down but mark
is gonna continue doing shows yeah when
when when fat man beyond goes dark mark
takes things in a darker during thank
you thank you my place I was waiting
what is it called
black man Beyond between spinoff
you're the Laverne and Shirley in this
[ __ ] man amazing I'm like the mod of
this [ __ ] our references are old you're
like the flash of this [ __ ] man here we
go yeah on the 22nd of October Tricia
Helfer is gonna join me here behind the
bar Wow yes right here caprica-six as a
mainstay of Battlestar Galactica here at
the scum and villainy Cantina indeed yes
and so she's going to pretend to be me
and I'm gonna pretend to be you and this
is gonna be weird what she's gonna be
you well yeah cuz I got a I got a stand
over there and then I gotta say all of
the things and then she and I but then I
still got to be me because I got to do
the news it's gonna be weird yeah oh
you're all I'm hearing is I'm getting
replaced by a white lady well that's
gonna be fun how many of those you got
planned right now I have two for sure
Trish is gonna come on the 22nd and Todd
stashwick is going to come here on the
5th of November he's an actor he's an
actor and a as big a Batman fan as I
have ever met ever he was on [ __ ]
Gotham like that's how much a bigger fan
he is than I am I was never on Gotham I
don't think you ever watched much Gotham
evite choice choice and then I think
we're gonna put together a show on the
29th of October sort of a horror
roundtable show oh [ __ ] yeah based
around what based around it's two days
before Halloween
make sense are gonna salander's say yeah
put him together who's gonna be the
guest list but I think Clark wolf is
gonna come back she was a she was a
guest once before when you were gone
I'm hoping the Djinn Yamato from the LA
Times is gonna come down and then Latoya
Morgan who's a TV writer and we're gonna
talk about um [ __ ] horror and ladies
and ladies in horror and how it's a
different experience for women to watch
our than it is for men and I'm just
going to watch and shut up as is my job
well done man yeah all right so that's
you got that to look forward to there's
still activities going on here well like
next Tuesday if you guys are like just
like so craving hanging out with one of
us at the at the Alamo Drafthouse down
oh yeah yeah they asked me said hey do
you have a movie that you love that
you'd love to come and introduce on the
big screen and I said I'd love to do
attack the block and they said yeah you
should do attack the block and so next
Tuesday at the draft house I'm gonna
introduce and talk about and hang out
and so come watch [ __ ] Finn and
Doctor Who kill aliens with me at the
draft house and this beer it's like
being at a bar really just there's also
a movie about have you been there - the
sound I've been there twice I mean I
went for the opening night and I went
for a birthday party and both of those
birthday party look pretty but it was
[ __ ] amazing because this dude his
wife threw him a surprise raid as the
Lost Ark birthday party so everybody
showed up like in [ __ ] cosplay I wore
I wore the I'm the only black dude and
Raiders outfit which is basically just
me like I need to put on a ton of [ __ ]
and a little captain's hat because
they're black Katanga who's the captain
oh yeah oh my god leave us the girl
my losses on this trip you know
memorized your one line for the part
that might slavery for the win yo so so
yeah bunch of people just have been
cosplaying we went in and watch the
movie they had an obstacle course before
the movie started getting older they had
a giant beach ball I know right so first
he has to do like a little hop scotch on
Jehovah but the Latin alphabet begins
with an i right and then and then he had
to limbo under the [ __ ] like spiky
thing and then took a shot and then
punch it Nazi in the face and then run
around the theater and as you ran around
the theater he was chased by the giant
[ __ ] beach ball Boulder it's pretty
impressive
banaram yeah that's a party that's a
party so again man I like it down there
if I don't I'm glad it's as far away as
it is because if it was closer I'd be
there all the time all the [ __ ] time
but I'm using it like a tree yeah treat
yourself alright so you can go see mark
when next Tuesday 9 p.m. at the Alamo
Drafthouse beautiful techtube look look
at you getting out there man
brand-building
trying baby I'm trying I like it what
else you've been doing I saw you put up
a tweet about like you were busy today
yeah I today begins for pitch meetings
that I have for a television show that
that I invented and I'm now trying to
get networks to want to put on the air
so it involves me sort of going into
these rooms and doing a little tap dance
and then telling them sort of
soup-to-nuts what the show is for about
half an hour 40 minutes of like here all
the characters here's the world here's
what the first season looks like yours
with the second through fifth season
looks like and then give me hundreds of
millions of dollars to make it yeah so
it's a small ask
I mean it's casual
it's not like pressure or anything all
right but I can't say very much more
beyond that I can't say what the show is
I can't say where I've gone when I can I
will write but the process is very much
like do you like it I hate pitching I
feels to hat in hand to me which I got
no problem receiving help or something
like that but like you know it's it's
you are it's if I don't if I don't get a
yes the thing doesn't happen here I
don't like to play it like that it's too
to Vegas to me I like to cheat you know
what I'm saying like make sure that it's
gonna happen never mind leaving my fade
up to some other [ __ ] fool yeah I
mean the one thing that I like about it
is that I love this story and I love
this project so and continued money to
do it and I need the money to do it but
like if some dude wants to talk to me
for 45 minutes about a thing that I love
then I mean I'd do that here for free
well you pay for it but no like it's
it's super fun like to talk with
enthusiasm a lot of thing that you like
is is kind of dreamy it's it's why you
get into this business to help tell
stories and dance all your Hitchings
like did it live up to what you thought
it was before you ever run in and
pitched something
no no because there's not like I every
time I go in to pitch I expect like
Orson Welles to bring out the stand of
rich and famous contract at the end of
the pitch he never [ __ ] does because
hey he's dead and that's not how it
works
but the first time that I pitched this
thing I was first I was pitching to
studios now we're pitching the network's
the first time I pitched it was a week
after you had a heart attack and then
yeah remember
it's a whole thing
I'm starting to tie the two together man
yeah like you're like my best chance at
[ __ ] selling this is a sympathy play
my buddy's dead it's an instant sale
well yeah like you had a heart attack
and then a week after that I was at a
comic book signing for a friend and I
was driving home and like didn't feel
right right and and then I went home and
my wife's like oh you should maybe take
a blood pressure and I did and it had
like four numbers on it and it's only
supposed to have three and she was like
oh [ __ ] you need to go to the emergency
room I said oh [ __ ] I need to go in the
emergency room so I went to the
emergency room and I said I think I'm
having a heart attack
are you sure how do you know my best
friend just had when he told me all of
the things so I think it's that they
like stopped listening to Kevin Smith on
Twitter man he's not a hard doctor on TV
mm-hm
and so it turns out that I wasn't a
heart attack but like any number of
other issues like high blood pressure
and hypertension and you know pitching a
television show that oh you wonder nice
dress like yeah I'm gonna go in and ask
these people for like hundreds of
millions of dollars true to make good TV
shows
oh so stress then yes stress then but
the day after I went into the ER I had
the pitch and I went in and I sold it in
the room and I'm like well now I need to
go to the ER before every [ __ ] that's
the Whammy like if I don't have like a
[ __ ] wrist bracelet around it has my
name of my social security number on it
then I will AFOL come back mr. Bernard
on is it Netflix today yeah yeah that's
my name yeah yeah clear see yeah that
was that was a more interesting
experience just because I it felt a
little bit like I'm nothing to lose man
you just survived I'm not having a heart
attack
it's all good and then sold the show and
then sold the show you didn't have a
heart attack and you sold the show it's
like what the [ __ ] see this is somebody
really turned the simulation up right
you should try that next time what I
mean
don't have the heart attack and then
sell the TV show uh I'll be honest with
you I have the heart attack and I've
really benefited from it man like I
talked about that but now you know
before the heart attack
I was always like I made clerks ever
since our attack I'm like I had a heart
attack
like that's it give me something new to
talk about finally after like 25 years
I'm like something else happened yeah no
I actually benefited from it man I'm not
obviously like saved my wife in many
ways and stuff but like you know I'm
doing tons of press this week next week
because the movies coming out and and
I've so I tell this story where it's not
even a story I used this line quite a
bit because they're like you got a big
cast in this movie and I was like oh
yeah man I said that has everything to
do with the heart attack man because I'd
call up people and be like hey you want
come down to New Orleans and be and Jay
and Silent Bob take like an hour and
people be like New Orleans man it's a
long flight to go work for an hour I
don't know Kevin I'd be like you do
remember I almost [ __ ] died last year
you know like all right I'm [ __ ]
coming I'm coming so I said we should
credit the [ __ ] heart attack with the
casting on the movie because it really
brought the cast together and [ __ ] I
went to the movies what'd you say
I saw ad I struck Wow my lord
[ __ ] Brad Pitt over there how was it
it looked to me very interstellar II
it's I admired it more than I liked it
you know like it's it sounds like
interstellar it sounds like interstellar
it's gorgeous to look at James Gray who
directed this thing like he squeezed
every dollar that they had out of it
nice um so it's got a very like Kubrick
vibe but it it it is so like weirdly
emotionally distant because have you
seen the trailers there's a lot of
voiceover from Brad Pitt who's telling
you his emotional state which makes it
almost like a documentary after a while
like Brad Pitt isn't narrating his own
story and now the documentaries can't be
emotionally engrossing because they
totally can be yeah that one about mr.
Rogers made me cry like a [ __ ] truck
for sure
like three solo was maybe the scariest
thing I'd seen in a long while yeah yeah
did you not see free soul oh I didn't
then everybody keeps telling me to watch
it it's amazing but I mean he dies
[ __ ] spoilers man
does he maybe I'll be honest with you
may be interested in watching it yeah
everyone I know is like oh my god it's
breathtaking gotta see it and I'm like I
never go outside why would I watch a
movie about a guy who only goes outside
because that's the way to live life man
is it outside know that though through a
screen watching other people do [ __ ] huh
can a man a black mirror life for me but
like it's it's beautiful there's a
couple of really interesting scenes
there's a there's a fight a space monkey
I saw them there there are in in this
weirdly intellectual treatise on like
you know fathers and sons and like heart
of darkness going to rescue my dad on
the edge of the galaxy there's [ __ ]
space pirates and like rabid like space
pirates ya know on the surface of the
Moon where apparently it's like
corporatized and there's a bunch of
different you know live-action [ __ ] like
just over the future but yeah so Brad
Pitt's got a drive from like you know
[ __ ] sea of tranquillity base to the
Dark Side of the Moon to take a [ __ ]
that will then take him to Mars that
will then take him to no ship I'm like
what the plot is he's got to drive and
take a [ __ ] that was like on the direct
this movie he's taking a ship to the
Dark Sun why nobody's gone there before
no that's where the like secret
government shuttle launches from the
dark side why it's always the dark side
I don't know but it's and so he's on
this [ __ ] buggy
you know the buggies that you've seen on
the [ __ ] like you know Apollo
landings but he's driving that a bunch
of other buggies come around and they're
like shooting space guns at each other
like I did not see this coming
like pew pew yeah a little you have to
say pew pew because they can't say bang
bang because there's no air so you know
they can bus so how do they play it in
the scene do you hear anything or is it
just it's super silent except for when
somebody is in like the frame who's
holding a gun you hear like the muffled
sound of the gun go off but there's no
explosions there's no nothing just like
music and silence right I'm like oh [ __ ]
all right this is cool space moon pirate
car chase didn't see that happening and
then he goes to like a space station
that's calls for like a distress signal
and it turns out that they were doing
animal tests
and a bunch of like rabid baboons are
loose on this space station it's like
[ __ ] a like Brad Pitt's gotta fight
rabid baboons and a space station
finally something's happening in this
movie yeah and and then things stop
happening and then there's lots of like
longing full glances at like planets and
like somber voice-over about like I go
to get my dad I'm going to parent-child
that's a parent-child thing so it's it's
a always every time they want to do a
parent-child movie the like in space
it's always got to be in space so he's
got to be in space I mean it's it tries
for some of the the like remoteness and
and sort of veracity of something like
gravity yes but with none of the
emotional content of something like
gravity so it's really pretty look at
but ultimately not about very much
trying to remember gravity gravity opens
like pretty hardcore
and then spoilers like he don't make it
right and then it's just her by herself
for a long time one of the most amazing
experiences ever had in a theatre was
sitting just I was watching gravity
sitting just behind Buzz Aldrin and why
was he sitting there the whole time
going [ __ ]
a little bit a little bit like he'd sit
there like he'd be super silent maybe
like it's messier than that in space
he'd be like nothing is that clear this
is full of garbage like fifty years ago
it was a [ __ ] dung heap because all
the satellites don't go anywhere so they
just stay in orbit it's like yeah you
can't suck but then he would say oh
that's India because he knows what India
looks like from space good like this is
so weird all I'm getting out of this
story is maybe the most irritating
person to watch a movie with would be
Buzz Aldrin and yeah kind of all
spanning awesome guy no boss a real
American era but yeah this ain't gravity
well [ __ ] y'all sooner or later I'll see
it because I like Brad Pitt and but I
wasn't kind of rushing out to say yeah
just like I'm sure Brad Pitt ain't
rushing out to see Jay and Silent Bob
reboot coming soon you never can tell
what did I do this week I didn't go to a
movie I went over the weekend I went to
present again cuz like I'm on the press
rounds I went to I Heart Radio there
festival and you Vegas and stuff
and that was probably the largest crowd
I was ever in front of they're like
you're gonna present with Ryan Seacrest
and Ryan Seacrest like occurs to me like
the President of the United States not
our current president but the one from
the movies like anytime you like you see
somebody whose life is scheduled down to
the second like he showed up literally
12 seconds before we had to jump out on
air and stuff expertly [ __ ] delivered
his thing we walked offstage and he was
like great to see you man and he was off
like a shot there's a chopper waiting
for him totally and [ __ ] he's like I
gotta go save the president and uh
it was it was pretty impressive but I
never seen a crowd that big was at the
arena out there in Vegas and boy it was
a big [ __ ] crowd I saw Mumford & Sons
perform like real close it's about
eighty six dudes in that band man it's a
lot of what I don't know who the lead
singer was are good what does it feel
like when 86 dudes all go like hey Oh
like right in front of you heart
palpitations they were like they told me
at one point because we went out to the
floor and then like we were gonna have
to get ready for the presentation thing
so they were trying to get back and they
were moving traffic in front of us and
[ __ ] and so they're like you gotta wait
and I was like I will wait I will wait
did they did they stars born you did
they like call you out on stage like
yeah if you gotta sing this song could
you imagine I've been amazing I'd be
telling a way different story tonight
that's how I'd open I was like I sang
with Mumford and Sons and I know that's
your impression of Mumford know that
that is my ally from Star Wars boring oh
[ __ ] I went there just taking me to that
movie I'm suddenly thinking about that
play like that scene in the parking lot
where you know she puts peas on her hand
and [ __ ] you know for a drunken
degenerate he's cute I liked his
delivery - man I gotta think he's
talented that movie's good actually I
watched it when it came out in the
theaters and then I watched it again
when it hit a home video and stuff cuz
the first time I watch it was my mother
and I'm pretty sure it made her wet and
then
there are times when I see them comin
and there are times when they just
pulled in from periphery and just in the
VIP seconds I'm watching at home I
appreciated his craftsmanship even more
he's a really good director all right so
wait what was I did that
well said I [ __ ] do there's something
happening oh that's right it's this this
week ladies and gentlemen at the
herbarium which is a weed dispensary on
La Brea but by the target you know best
buy Plaza and stuff we're introducing me
and Jay moving into the weed business in
Jay and Silent Bob reboot a part of the
plot as Jay and SAAM Bob create three
strains of weed snoogantay chubu cheese
and berserker and so I always I always
wanted to like you know [ __ ] I want it
to be real in real life and [ __ ] like
when we did tusks for one month there
was two strains of mr. mr. tusk and
white walrus weed that was available at
head buds and roses and I was like
that's so cool but this is like like
this is this might my dopey little kind
of dream where I'm like if we can make
the weed happen in real life like then
it was all worth it you know what I'm
saying like then it doesn't matter what
people think about the movie it's like
yeah but it gave birth to our little
weed business so all right my favorite
weed in the world is put out by caviar
gold I [ __ ] love this [ __ ] it's
amazing it's the weed that like smokers
smoke to get high so caviar Mikey gotta
runs the company met with me and I was
like I want to make these three strands
of weed and he was like done so on
Friday the 27th at herbarium starting at
4:20 you can literally buy weed from Jay
and Silent Bob James ah Bob are
be they're presenting their new strains
me and J so people buy like free joints
and we take a picture with him and [ __ ]
like that and just the Mike who runs
caviar like he had this idea where he
texted me out of the blue somewhere he
was like hey man what if we put little
comics into the pre-rolls and I was like
what do you mean he's like you know how
you get the gum and you open up the
comic strip I was like like Bazooka Joe
he's like yeah but Berserker J and I was
like yes so I wrote like a bunch of
different comics like it's so fun cuz
three panels so it's [ __ ] easiest [ __ ]
so a bunch of three pound strips that
Steve stark who did Jay and Silent Bob
super groovy cartoon movie he drew and
so each one each joint comes with a
little like comic strip rolled up in it
and if you collect all ten you could
turn it and get a free joint but in two
of the joints that go on sale on Friday
eggs that's when we did you the weed
Mike put in a golden ticket so you could
win a thousand bucks as well just for
smoking weed man they should have to
they should be able to win your house
what do you mean like [ __ ] Wonka
style like they got the golden ticket
come in here come with me no we can't
give away the shop I'm just getting into
the weed business man now they will be
in a world of pure imagination once they
smoke this [ __ ] I assure you the smoochy
bujji's is a caviar golds first sativa
and it tastes like maple maple syrup
it's smoked it tastes like you're
smoking Canada it's pretty impressive so
Friday it begins at 4:20 minima throw
these up here on the bar I'm sure
someone will you know someone passed
these out as folks leave
feel free to attend or not attend and
stuff but yeah I'm squarely in the weed
business I love the fact that that
America is a place where a Hollywood
filmmaker can make his dreams come true
yes you know it was kind of sweet I just
I'm so delighted that like after years
of selling weed at being a fake weed
dealer in the movie
I get to be a real weed dealer in real
life and my mother is like always like
just don't become a drug dealer and now
I am alright is that all the opening
stuff almost before we get to the news
yes there there's a couple in the crowd
who reached out to us and said hey you
know what be awesome we're having a baby
and we don't know what gender this baby
is gonna be so would you guys be down
with doing the gender reveal on fat man
beyond [ __ ] yeah yeah and I said [ __ ]
yeah so uh Richard and Katie where are
you guys hey oh come on gang hi how are
you you must be Richard yeah how you
give it up for Richard Katie ladies
gentlemen now this is a relatively new
thing in the world of kids when I had a
kid this wasn't a thing where they could
you surprised they [ __ ] told you and
she'll like that how did you avoid
finding out what's inside of you it
sounded dirtier than I meant it but you
know what I mean like how do well how do
you avoid like do you have to tell them
in advance like if you [ __ ] breathe a
word you ruin everything like to the
doctor who's gonna deliver the baby like
yeah well they called and said we have
the results and she heard that said I
don't want to know because I made a bet
with her that if he all said yes then we
couldn't fly here today today and do
this who won the bet you yeah I think
Mark said yes
wow man and that has been sitting on our
counter for about three weeks and she's
been going crazy
oh [ __ ] three weeks [ __ ] that bet why
didn't you open that envelope
get over it oh my god all right so this
is a big deal man and we're just like
[ __ ] prolonging it I know but I
really got to know the how does how do
do they they give you this like they
sent it to you and they called us with
those results and then they said they
would leave that at the desk for me to
pick up the next appointment so Wow man
all right what what are you guys hoping
for or I mean sorry on the same team
about it I mean I know everybody was a
baby of course they're hoping for a baby
yeah everybody's like I just want the
baby to be healthy and ten fingers and
ten toes and all that [ __ ] he wants a
boy boy either way just baby how come
nobody ever says dragon especially in
this part all right so either sex is
good man all right all right let's go
man anything you want to say before this
happens this is the last moment of the
rest of your life like I I have a kid
and it all changes man and and you know
what I'll be honest with you there is a
better sex I'm not going to tell you
which one it is but anyway in any event
this is a big moment this is the last
moment of your young lives and stuff
from now forward you're always gonna
know what's on the way whether you're
gonna have a boy or a girl so last
thoughts we can't do that for you yeah I
mean we could try I guess like
I believe you're the one that has to
make it a boy or girl right so why don't
you make it a [ __ ] boy if I remember
my baby make it correctly a boy is the
easier one to make right like it takes
[ __ ] super sperm to turn it into a
girl maybe that's just what my wife told
me yeah
I believed her I was like I have super
sperm she's like yes you do
I was gonna say the baby is the easiest
part that's think it makes a baby that's
true in it all right now you realize
once we open this we also have to be
there for the for the birth you have to
if it's a you are looking for prima
nocta right no I'm just saying we I mean
we're gonna deliver this baby because
now we're in that business if you can
sell wheat I can be an OB that's true
and I support your dreams so please let
him deliver your baby all right who's
got a drumroll I'm gonna be honest with
you this envelope is already hey stop it
the envelope is torn
yeah JC opened it to make sure that it
wasn't like crazy medical tech that we
wouldn't be able to decipher it hold the
[ __ ] phone this poor woman's been
waiting how long to open the envelope
and she resisted all [ __ ] urges and
it gets here in JC's like oh well so I'm
the only one who knows you do know you
looked yes SARS unfair all right okay
back to the drum roll drum roll drum
roll please ladies gentlemen
okay we we have a winner there's a baby
and there is a sax there totally is
often kids
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my lord give it up from Congrats kids
you'll want that envelope Katie you can
take that envelope now and you could
either keep it and put it in a scrapbook
or burn that [ __ ] that taunted you for
so long
there you go frame that one there it is
man oh my god life oh sweet man
yeah that's great [ __ ] I've never been
involved in one of them me neither
I mean I've had two children and they
reveal their genders but I weren't an
envelope yes was a uterus yeah no I've
never been involved in somebody else's
mm-hmm it's kind of cool
it could be a new thing I know come on
down for gender reveals or we just stop
talking about pop culture and all we do
is gender their babies all the time and
I mean at least once a day
totally what was that just real quick
what was the bat hold on JC's coming
back with a mic of which part like what
was that what was the bet that got you
here that she doesn't really watch our
show but I watch it this and Hollywood
babble-on and I told her I was like I
love these guys and if one of them says
yes can we just fly up here and do it
she said yeah sure not thinking y'all
we're gonna say yes so that's not a bet
she was just more like I love you and
I'll do anything for you but in the back
of her mind she's like they're never
gonna [ __ ] man when they called you
like ah ha yeah yeah ladies the kind of
person I'd want to have a kid with too
you know
[Music]
that's beautiful man well thank you for
letting us be a part of that it was
[ __ ] straight we have no further
opening business we have no further
opening distant let us go right to the
[ __ ] meat of it all mr. mark barnard
and ladies and gentlemen if you don't
know this before he was out there
pitching TV shows he was a guy that was
a news hound man he was a journal AK if
you will and they called Matt right yeah
interest
I was also and he he's the guy
responsible every episode for digging up
the news because he's got a nose for
news mark found some news first give it
up for mark barnard he's got the news
[Applause]
did uh did you watch any of the Emmys on
Sunday night I did not what was that
doing I watched succession okay which I
[ __ ] love and what else did I watch I
think that was a no I actually went back
and watched like previous episodes of
succession the Emmys did happen I heard
that happened game of thrones won
something Game of Thrones won
Outstanding Drama Series did they ever
do that before they have indeed so it's
not quite be like hey you did it gang
the way the Oscars pulls it like yeah
return the King gets win best picture
but really it's for all three of them
right you know like Al Pacino wins for
Scent of a Woman but really it's for the
other 40 movies you've made before that
that are way better than zel one for for
training day and Malcolm and alchemax
yeah so everybody the Oscars will do to
sort of make good slash Lifetime
Achievement Award
so this felt a little bit like that if
only because we all watch the eighth
season of Game of Thrones right and
we're all like well outstanding
I mean good at daunting standing
what was it up against it was up against
I don't remember the total litany of it
but like what is another drums arc this
is us
you forget shet me Game of Thrones is in
the same categories this is us yeah that
makes no [ __ ] sense whatsoever
one has a dragon it does it really does
this is us has gotten weird in the last
three seas
wow that's [ __ ] strange and then what
one best commerce fleabag fleabag one I
did love that so much like [ __ ] grey
she's talented and Dinklage won for a
Best Supporting Actor for like the
fourth time yeah he's great he's anyone
else win from Game of Thrones no kid
Harrington no no they all showed up
though including Gwendoline Christie I
saw a picture of her
Logan very tall she's huge and he looked
like a catholic saint precisely as very
beatific very much like casting
blessings on the entire crowd yeah but
yeah it's it was the lowest rated Emmys
I think in history some of it because
there was I mean you tuned it to the
Emmys for a show like that half the time
because of who's hosting the Emmys you
know it's always like oh it's [ __ ]
Tina Fey and Amy Poehler oh it's it's
Colbert oh it's you know the host this
year there was no host this year well
that's smart
yeah why I think because they'd enter
for the Oscars when the whole game of
that particular they had a [ __ ] issue
where they're like we lost our host
right but like it seemed to have worked
out okay like the ratings didn't dip for
the Oscars like it seemed to hold steady
and then like well maybe we could try
this [ __ ] maybe we'll see what happens
but it turns out that for the Emmys
people want to actually hear somebody
tell jokes hmm and like do a dumbass
musical number that was missing as well
um they eventually did a dumbass musical
number but it's like in the middle of
the show and the [ __ ] wanted that man
you gotta come heavy with the musical
number or don't come at hoedown at all
well what does this mean for the Emmys
will they finally [ __ ] stop this
thing yes this was the last enemies who
did Bill Hader win an award he did he
wore for directing that means it for
directing yeah those I'll tell you those
Barry episodes are very well directed
and he did directly one for directing
and Jason Bateman one for directing a
drama those episodes the Ozark episodes
are very well directed to both of those
[ __ ] shows I've watched and been like
these guys are better directors than me
and my wife's in the room she's like
they're all better directors than you
kept but you made a girl your sperms
powerful changed a boy or girl I got
that going for me
now you've lurks an art attack check it
all the [ __ ] did you bring up the Emmys
for a reason other than to gloat at the
fact
ratings drop just the game of Thrones
but all just the final farewell to that
show that they I said my goodbyes I was
there there's a giant tree behind us and
everything I remember that so moving on
they are the Batman picture that Matt
Reeves is directing which is starring
Rob Pattinson correct
they've there's been another potential
casting is that we're gonna talk about
who's been to other potential castings
oh I heard that too that's right I heard
him both last night as well this is
exciting man Jeffrey right say it say it
what what do what me say Lange the
Commish brilliant excellent choice yeah
the moment I saw that in print I was
like wow what a great fight like that in
a hard yes he's got the perfect [ __ ]
gravitas for that role and he's a great
actor enough to pull off like you know
cuz Commissioner Gordon's got to be like
[ __ ] he's my partner man like I'm
hunka I believe in Batman as [ __ ] but
there always has to be an air of like I
can't believe I believe in Batman
you know these please risking a lot for
a dude who's just like you don't know
who I am
I'm gonna put a stapler in your net yeah
like if he can if he can make like felix
leiter an interesting character in the
bond movies who only gets like four
lines in any one of those movies but
when he rose up mrs. my brother from
Langley yes that might make him a man
who walks between two worlds cuz wasn't
he isn't he supposed to be the voice of
a wah - he is in the what-if series so
he'll be Marvel one-foot Marvel one foot
in DC he's got that sweet big - comic
money coming man [ __ ] I want some of
that
alright so wait but that's the one big
casting thing which I thought was
brilliant enough if they just said that
that would have been big that would have
been enough but then the bigger news was
this Jonah Hill now instantly the
internet was like I'll come on it better
not be penguin and [ __ ]
that's too on the nose and it turns out
it's not penguin the last I read I'm not
sure if there were updates later today
but it was unspecified villain roll
I heard the rap was reporting that it
was Riddler
really yes hmm I'm still a little I
would I would almost rather that it was
like to face like go Harvey Dent like
don't don't go funny and don't go fat
because that's what I expect out of both
of those that's why I think a lot of
people were like I hope it's not the
penguin yeah that would have seemed like
the more obvious choice stuff
Riddler I can see I'm all for it man I
think he's a really good actor I already
watched wolf of Wall Street last night
it's really good
did the slate engine did you see the
trailer for what the [ __ ] is it it's
Adam Sandler's like yes and it feels
like Sam was like [ __ ] it if Jonah Hill
can get a [ __ ] Oscar nomination I can
get an Oscar nomination
I just [ __ ] well I never thought he
was a bad actor I mean if anything you
know this is not my opinion he could be
accused of making bad choices or
whatever the [ __ ] in the movies if you
don't like his stuff but obviously
stuff's been very commercial but I never
thought he was like a bad actor that
Paul Thomas Anderson movie is really
yeah that when I saw the trailer I was
like he might there's gonna be Oscar
buzz like he wind up being nominated at
the very least it looks good it does
look good I like those filmmakers man
the Safety's like they make some good
[ __ ] make me feel old when I watch their
movies I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm an old man
getting up does that for me but so the
Batman is coming out in 20 21 20 21
yeah are you sure I think so I heard 20
20 June 25th 20 21 [ __ ] sorry
[ __ ] me I have to wait like [ __ ] a
year and a half or a new Batman movie
you do this world oh well we got bat
woman come and that'll hold the so yeah
bat woman come in here there's any
number of Batman video games he's
joining fortnight you could play
fortnight in the Batman Universal in
Gotham City I know this because Jason
Mewes woke me at 3 in the morning
to [ __ ] tell me that four nights
adding Batman I was like oh my gosh my
mother okay what the [ __ ] but no you
will get to see the Joker far sooner
then you'll get to see the Batman of
course we're about to see the Joker in
any minute now the billboards are up
tickets around cyborgs are up the
tracking is that it's going to be the
biggest October release ever and I mean
that doesn't surprise me at all what
does that mean do they have a figure
it's tracking now between 80 and 85
million opening weekend I'm like I'm not
a good at this kind of [ __ ] but I'd bet
that it opens to three figures that
movie got to open to 100 because the
buzz is loud now and that's before like
you know John Q average and Sally
whatever have heard about the movie like
this is all film world people that are
excited about this [ __ ] they haven't
even broken into the mainstream wait
till the mainstream gets a load of this
man oh my god they're gonna be like holy
[ __ ] it's a must-see movie as must-see
written all over thank you yeah that's
good news good call back well then yeah
this movie I bet you it makes 100
million bucks opening weekend in my in
my although there is there's one theater
where it will not be playing where
Aurora yeah it will not be sent it will
not be playing at the Cinemark Aurora
theater where the 2012 Dark Knight Rises
mass shooting take place yeah took place
because didn't he he colored his haired
and he was dressed a little joke yeah
and as a joint decision between botha
theatre and Warner Brothers both both
parties were like this would be in bad
taste so we're not gonna do that
so it'll make a hundred million less the
three grand that it might have made at
that theater right I mean honestly
that's like a very tasteful decision it
is makes all the sense because it's not
like you know I'm sure there's another
movie theater in town I've just not
[ __ ] there I'm surprised that's still
open they changed the name but yeah they
opened it up again thoughts this is it
there's a school of thought that's like
you know [ __ ] terror but if we close the
theater the terrorists win so I guess it
makes sense yeah and you know and the
people who live in that town deserves to
be able to see whatever movies they'd
like to see it seems as if the town is
spoken that they don't want this one
right because understand understandable
but yeah I mean it's it is still a place
where we can all go on in a perfect
world and trust that the dark won't hurt
us
I kind of admit man I feel really bad
right now cuz I'm like wow like that is
so far back in the news cycle when it
was still like shocking when I was like
why there's a mass shooting where yeah
how many years ago was that now 2012 Wow
and we did a spoilers episode about it
right around that time that's right I
saw a picture of it online recently
somebody snapped a picture of you and I
together they're like oh [ __ ] a [ __ ]
fat man spotted in the wild or something
like that Secret Origins he has all
right so that makes sense that makes
sense so bring boy that brought the room
down yes sorry sorry all like the
Joker's gonna be great there like not
nor or I'm like yeah right
forgot about that let's see the CW is
planning and now the sixth spinoff from
the arrow verse ya know what so wait
let's do em all first there was arrow
arrow then there was flash duh then
there was a super girl yes
then there was legend then there was
that woman no before that what about
black lightning that's gotta count I
mean it didn't spin out but it you don't
exist without those and it's a Berlanti
show you don't need a mr. Deasy show
when they are crossing over now in
crisis yes yes six God account
so then Batwoman not six oh wait there's
has there been anything before Batwoman
so the last new show they did was
legends Black Lightning Black Lightning
yeah I guess that's all of them yeah
alright keep doing the math so that's
that woman is six this new thing will be
seven Jesus so that's seven spin-offs or
six spin-offs six minutes of the
original from the original is that
there's got to be some sort of record in
TV history
no yeah I mean I think I heard that it
was like well I'm not because I don't
know the record holder but like happy
date well love American style spawned
happy days which spawn Laverne and
Shirley which spawn Mork and Mindy
which born spawn Joanie Loves Chachi
which spawned two Broke Girls that was a
spinoff and then all the family was
another show generator starts as all the
family Jenny gets the Jeffersons Maude
right Archie Bunker's place Gloria was a
spinoff at one point they did another
Archie Bunker's spin-off like ten years
ago set at the address I forget what the
address was yeah so they got like six or
seven out of that u21 racist lame
but wow that is that's a bunch of I
think I think Star Trek might take the
cake how because you had Star Trek you
had the animated Star Trek you had next
generation you had Deep Space nine
you've had Voyager you've had Enterprise
and now you have discovery and you're
getting Picard and then there's gonna be
lower decks I think look nominated yeah
the animated comedy you're right that's
a lot that's a lot but the time was
there like it took them 45 years to do
that
where's arrows doing it in six yeah I
mean arrow pretty much helped build all
those shows built help built the CW
pretty lore gem and of course
supernatural supernatural and the spine
of the CW network started as a non CW
show as a UPN you kid was not not
Europeana what was it called WB WB
arrived at the Frog yeah there's the one
and she owned one of the only shows that
lasted from WB into see they're like
let's rebrand you know who people love
the [ __ ] frog from that one episode
of Bugs Bunny they to be fair everyone
did love that frog but choosing him as
the corporate spokesperson over Bugs
Bunny do you know who do you think Bugs
Bunny was like you chose the [ __ ]
frog I'm the [ __ ] [ __ ] you guys
hopefully the corners brothers what
happens next then so they're doing an
offshoot it's a female centric offshoot
with let's see its revolving around me a
smoke who's known as I guess the new
Green Arrow
and the Canaries Laurel Lance and Dinah
Drake oh so they're gonna keep it going
the birds of prey oh yes but this
indicates that while they're finishing
arrow we know that they're finishing
arrow so I don't know what they're
calling this show yet they haven't given
it a title but but one of the episodes
in the last season of arrow was going to
be a backdoor pilot for this show in the
same way that they did the same they did
it with a flash like the flash was
introduced in an episode of arrow and
running out from there yeah we're going
on this city okay cool these people
that's what's gonna happen here with a
lower voice just that curiosity well I
mean if you've already got an arrow show
why stop it and start a new arrow show
from a business perspective cheaper
cheaper because you don't have to pay
everyone like in their sixth year
totally you my everyone like a first
year show right for it for every season
of a show everybody gets paid more the
writers get paid more the cast it
definitely gets paid more and so by the
end of the show you're spending more
than you're making so the easiest way to
financially square that circle is okay
new show everybody's getting you know
the entry-level fees and then five years
later hey you know what'd be great new
show guys oh I know you thought you're
doing well but new show guys you could
see it coming man yeah speak what is it
that's right Constantine wait is that a
that wasn't a Berlin T show though it's
an NBC yeah well he's actually now
involved with urology's on legends I
don't know if that counts it's not part
of the traditional Berlin fevers as we
understand it to be and then one is
Batwoman begin I've been seeing bus ads
and stuff so early October October 6th I
think speaking of the Berlin diverse Tom
Welling is showing up in crisis the
worst kept secret in the business when
they announced it I was like what a
surprise
delightful when I first heard this news
months ago it was delightful my god
that's they're getting everybody man it
makes sense big question will he wear
the S because you know he didn't wear
the S ever mmm even in that last shot
when he [ __ ] in Smallville when he
finally revealed the S they shot him
blank chested and put the S on a post
because apparently he's believes in the
Superman urges to the letter
well the the Superman curse anyone who
wears the S like you know [ __ ] George
Reeves Christopher Reeves and stuff like
that so I guess he believed that that's
what I'd heard I mean is Dean Cain in a
bunker somewhere no he's still around I
think but yeah I wonder if he'll wear
the ass like is he gotten over that
suspicion a superstition I mean here's
my guess is he doesn't wear them because
they already had these two other dudes
wearing the S I mean it's crisis on
Infinite Earths so you could have a
bunch of Superman I know he's got to
wear the ass if you don't wear the ass
we revolt you know I forget I'm not even
deeply invested in that aspect of it but
I think he should wear these especially
because he spent so much time not
wearing the S so now he just only wears
SS t hats make him earn it I you the I'm
actually think they're gonna pay him
that's got a he's not doing out of the
kindness of his heart like you know they
had to see W had to open up the cash
register man yeah [ __ ] yeah I know
you're like what's he been doing lately
he's set for life man set for life cuz
of that show and he's got other [ __ ]
going on so like and famously he's been
he's been very reticent
yeah and no-goodnik going nowhere near
it so so yeah I'm sure they bought him
lunch at least gotta be more than lunch
I got good lunch though like in the
world of TV if you're making this
crossover event mm-hmm like I'm not
gonna say you need him but you kind of
do you don't have any of these shows
without Smallville that's fair if I was
him I'd cash in big test like lunch and
dinner
like thank God he doesn't have his agent
yeah I'm excited about that then Erica
Durance is returning his Lois Lane oh
that's cool yes cool so that'll be fun
um what else we got hold
speaking of supernatural yeah a little
off-brand they are really really I'm
Brad we just don't really talk about did
you ever watch Supernatural no man Jason
Mewes every episode
there's too many episodes he's seen them
all I would love somebody to be like
here's the ten you need to watch and not
like the you should start like season
four and then just plow on through I
mean he's only gonna be like 200
episodes of television but you're not
busy I'm sure I've told this story
before but when I was working on Reaper
mmm CW I directed the pilot when we
thank you I was not holding for that but
cloggin thank you when we did it and
they bought the pilot they were like
we're gonna take this to series in ship
the head of the network at the time Dawn
was her name I forget Olmstead I don't
think it was that she said stars yeah I
think was that yeah don't summers now
that's Buffy sister I forget her name
but any event she said this is gonna
come in at just the right time she's
gone because we're almost done with
supernatural so this could take over for
Supernatural that was 25 years ago it
was a while ago man supernatural just
kept [ __ ] going and they finally
announced that they're done right they
finally messed that they're done but one
of them supernatural boys is going off
to do another thing gotta be Jared
Padalecki hold yeah
yes it's coming through now calm Jared
Padalecki is going off to reboot Walker
Texas Ranger I mean I just always
associated that very heavily with you
know dollars yeah it seems like it was
all dependent on Chuck Nori's if it
seemed like hey they're gonna reboot
Mork & Mindy like without Robin Williams
what's the point in [ __ ] but if anybody
can pull it off it's the guy who has
made 183 years of super nap the audience
loves them and I come sure it'll work
yeah no CBS is getting back in the
Walker business CBS so he's gone from
CWD CBS and stuff yeah CBS Studios The
CW is happy to have it as the network
like the Mark Pedowitz is I don't know
he can come back whenever he wants Mark
Pedowitz man like why he was talking
about supernatural at one point we were
at a dinner up in Vancouver like when
they start their season like they have
like he comes up and takes all the casts
out to dinner and stuff so I was working
on an episode when he came up like they
were like you get to go to dinner too
and I said how long you keep going with
supernatural and like serious as a heart
attack
Mark Pedowitz goes will make that show
as long as those boys want to make that
show and he wasn't kidding man like they
just [ __ ] dialed in and totally if I
can made that show for years and years
and years you know some things never get
old some things never die Walker Texas
Ranger CBS Wow Walker fan as a kid I
mean no no no like but not because I'm
like [ __ ] that job is just never on my
rep see more like a show my dad would
enjoy I don't even think my dad watched
that one it was never the sort of thing
where you like I just happen to be here
and we're watching Walker I know should
I turns out I love Walker and I'll see
you guys in 12 years after Walker if I
if I had ever watched why the only way I
would have gotten into Walker is if
they're like now he's putting on a cape
and cowl
and that big [ __ ] yeah Walker man did
what was the show that your parents
watch that you got Tribune into watching
them became a fan of dynasty my mother
would always watch dynasty and I'm like
[ __ ] OMA can we watch anything else
she's like no I like this I like
watching the money that's what she said
so you know I was just stuck watching
because there's the other that or do
homework we didn't have the internet it
was like three channels or [ __ ] go to
sleep so she'd watched that at 10
o'clock at night and I watch it with her
and it was weird it was like seeing a
different side of my mother like really
engrossed in these [ __ ] ridiculous
storylines and [ __ ] like that about
infidelity and make me go like mom did
you ever cheat on dad you bite your
tongue but if I was gonna be with him
you know what people on the show that
she presumably was talking about [ __ ]
man and I was like so I got to see a
different version to her when I watch
that show and then I got roped in and
was invested and [ __ ] like just like in
the storyline and then when they brought
in Alexis Carrington when they brought
in Western em Joan
they don't call in Joel Collins holy
[ __ ] show took a big jump and she was
like one of those you hate her but you
gotta watch her like fun to hate
characters and stuff and my mom would
always like my mom is so [ __ ]
Catholic brush never [ __ ] cursed ever
she'd always be like oh he double hockey
sticks she wouldn't even say hell but
during [ __ ] dynasty whenever Joan
Collins would come on if I can't say
something to leave the scene my mom
would always go that [ __ ] it was so
programmed for
man what about you what did you watch
would you get sucked into uh General
Hospital oh [ __ ] really yeah mines your
mom my mom was a die-hard General
Hospital fan so she'd come home from
school and it was always around a three
o'clock time so we would want to watch
cartoons and that was not on the [ __ ]
menu because Luke and Laura were doing
[ __ ] but here's the thing the season
that I started watching with my mom it
was like the ice princess season where
there was like a weather Dominator well
that's right where it got really
ridiculous it got super [ __ ] like
basically it's like the rise of serpent
or [ __ ] I didn't like Port Charles where
like Scorpio is leading some weird-ass
[ __ ] quest to bring winter to Port
Charles the only time I almost watch
that show was when I heard because I
remember Walter Flanagan being like you
know they're doing some comic-book [ __ ]
on General Hospital right now I was like
how do you know he's like my mom watches
him and he said they got a Weather
Machine I was like that's some comic
book [ __ ] right there and they would
eventually drop that [ __ ] and so I'm
just watching them for their romance
between Luke and Laura who are now like
78 years old and still kicking it Genie
Francis and aha Anthony Moses named Tony
Geary thank you 9 co-star of
Disorderlies if I remember correctly Wow
he worked with Jeannie Frances yes but
he also worked with the fat boys so yeah
Walker Texas Ranger might be coming from
one of them supernatural boys and it'll
run for 15 years with no spin-offs I
guess the idea is just like you know
people know the name so they'll tune in
but you know I've it's very brand
identified with him like almost like a
show that was just kind of built for him
yeah I I'm just waiting for another
night writer if they bring me another
night writer I will be happy I thought
they did that haven't they done it a few
times and one time it was with like him
Hasselhoff came back right I think they
did like you know Knight Rider
mm something like that and then in 2010
I want to say like they did another one
with Will Arnett as the voice of KITT
what yeah it was supposed to be Val
Kilmer and the pilot had Val Kilmer's
voice but he turns out was the voice of
Chevy on the commercials and because
this kit was a Ford like [ __ ] you you
can't have Val Kilmer and then will
arnett just showed up is this a dream
that you had it's a dream that I often
have but it's actually all have it
actually really happened Jesus which car
the new kit the Mustang the kit from his
version see is that all the news that is
all the news give it up for Marquis
pound news man all right kids we've come
to the part of the show that seems to be
everybody's favorite man this is the QA
portion of the show where we ask you
good folks in the audience to let us
know what you want to know and we used
to like be all threatening about it and
be like hey man you gotta [ __ ] ask
questions that we can both answer or
else you know you're not going to play
and [ __ ] we don't have to do that
anymore because JC has folks what do
they write the questions down before
they come in now or something like that
it's betted but not vetted like take the
dangerous questions out we look for the
dangerous questions but there really are
none why why don't we do it this way now
because I don't want a roomful of people
angry at me that they didn't that I
didn't pick them and then at the end of
the show you guys go home and they like
sit here with crossed arms and really I
thought we had something man
fair enough all right so JC has gone
through the questions and picked out a
bunch three I guess not technically a
bunch of for us to do here tonight so
I'm doing two things at once and I
shouldn't they want you to sign that as
well it's for a little boy because they
like the show they said okay cool I
wasn't supposed to be here today
well remembered so JC's picked out three
questions and the folks that ATS asked
these questions they're gonna walk away
with the prize am i right they are
indeed two things this week two things
this week two things as week posters
right here you get a signed poster from
Nate our friend Nate dark Nate returns
right here does all of our our beautiful
show art this one here features me and
mr. mark barnard and it's signed by me
and mr. mark retardant it's also signed
by Nate so every when everybody who asks
the question gets one of those and then
of course as always man a good friend
Brett Deacon hooked us up with 4dx
tickets which they now give a sweet use
of reusable bags for you get these
tickets you get to go to a 40 X or
screen X screening a presentation of a
movie if you haven't done that yet kids
holy [ __ ] you must have way better [ __ ]
to do in life because nothing's better
than [ __ ] 40 X Man and I say that
having had a child
40x is a way to watch a movie where the
chair is moving and shoot and [ __ ] in
your face and [ __ ] making things
smell and whole [ __ ] room comes to
life and spins around if you're watching
Star Wars and the crawl goes your chair
goes back to match the [ __ ] crawl
it's a wonderful way to watch movie if
you've never seen one in 40 x3 people
tonight gonna win two tickets apiece and
they can go check out one of those yeah
they got Gemini man coming up as the
next 40 X that's the Will Smith movie
there Will Smith V Will Smith picture
yeah be honest with you I'm into
watching it but like when I saw the
trailer the big reveal their like you
know first there's Will Smith and then
they're like and look it's Will Smith
and I was like all right so they just
shot him twice and then but then
somebody was like nah man he's young and
I had to go watch the trailer again to
be like oh like maybe two weeks younger
like he literally looks like the same
guy man I don't think it's playing the
way they think it's playing no yeah I
think if it had been like Nicolas Cage
you're like oh [ __ ] that's a much
younger Nicolas Cage yeah but that just
looks like Will Smith from Tuesday you
know as opposed to Will Smith from today
is the the black don't crack effect is
that what that is pretty much which is
he's movable and unable and so like he
does look as young as he did on [ __ ]
fresh print because the years have never
relaxed they're just still [ __ ] out
there
Dumbo's guy that's true it's the years
it's the years it's all in the years all
right so you can go see Gemini man is
that what it's called Gemini man Gemini
man in 40 X will it be screen X as well
green X is another version it's your
chair don't move but they take up three
walls first you're looking ahead with
where the screen is and then they also
put information on both sides of the
walls we took everyone to go see
spider-man far from home and then a free
presentation by the screen X folks man
it was amazing according to Deacon
Gemini man is in screen X I don't know
if it's also in 40 X but definitely
screen app screen X's don't see it there
yeah all right man so we got three
question askers what's this about who's
this friend is this a gift for us he's
from you what is it
get up to the mic hold on that's
important what's your name young camper
JD everyone give it up for JD mug here
says correspondents go ahead explain sir
so that is Suicide Prevention Month
right now September a few years ago I
won't get too dark but my depression and
anxiety kind of took care of me took
hold of me and couldn't couldn't leave
the bedroom and I discovered a couple
YouTube videos podcasts comics artist
Pro secrets and you guys and your
camaraderie just your celebration of pop
culture it made me smile and laugh and
inspired me to get going and I created
this web series it's a web miniseries
called correspondence it's a suicide
prevention awareness web series I've
heard you guys are fans of Twin Peaks
yes and a lot of the Twin Peaks family
helped us out with that Sabrina as
Sutherland she's the executive producer
of the return she's an executive
producer here Michael Burrell Skip
Buckelew and Sheryl Lee who plays Laura
Palmer yeah she's in a couple of the
episodes for us
Wow and the series it's focused on a
hotline counselor I had my buddy Ted
Hornick write it he was a hotline
counselor for three years
so it's really authentic and you just
stay with the counselor every episode is
a call he receives and it's just
supposed to encourage people that might
be reluctant to call there's no reason
for that stigma to exist it's crude and
your guys's your company
at that time it really helped me and I
appreciate it very much
[Applause]
misfit misfit picture shows is the
production company and the YouTube
channel is misfit picture shows all the
content is there and actually I wanted
to take it a step further so we've
created a podcast it's like a comic book
club
I wanted to engage with people every
week we read a comic graphic novel
reveal what next week's is so people can
read along with us we talked about it we
rate it and at the end of every episode
the viewer can rate it as well ABCD and
then we just encourage comments and
that's on that channel as well and that
stuff wouldn't exist without you guys
kind of doing what you do so thank you
it exists because of you man I even up
for yourself
thank you pleasure
[Music]
then that nice to be involved in
somebody else's art we didn't have to do
anything we're still involved somehow
it's so nice all right
JC's picked three people JC who is the
first Galen beers
Galen hey let me go did you say Galen
Galen everyone give it up for Galen I
was all incredulous Galen is from plan
of the apes there's a character named
Galen in Planet the TV version planted
Apes that was their their friend in the
TV version yeah and there's a battle
start and then what is it
dragon dragon slayer hey let's write and
Dragon Slayer the character's name was
good and who yeah and generous those dad
yeah that's true oh and rogue one what
if it's all the same dude over and over
this secret history of galas
it's me I've been trying to get my name
out there yeah it's doing a great job
what can we do you for Galen well I was
just thinking how fun it would be and to
revisit Dawn of the Dead aren't they
doing that are they no are they doing a
what's his name George Romero no Zack
Snyder is doing like a zombie series mhm
okay well then
well I was easy no go ahead but I think
he is didn't I see that he's like army
of the day the Netflix move is that what
it is a Netflix movie a casino heist
during a zombie apocalypse Zak's back
ladies a Joe a little from column a
little from column B I loved his dawn of
the dead man like as a tough movie to
touch because I loved the original and I
thought he did a really good job mom
anyway back to you
hey Galen I was just thinking it was
really interesting because you know
online economy is killing the American
mall so I was just wondering if you
thought it should be set in an abandoned
mall or in an Amazon Fulfillment Center
yeah genius all right
we're doing a modern-day Dawn of the
Dead and it needs to be if it's gonna be
done of the Dead it also needs to be
kind of about consumerism and sort of
the economy and got to take place in a
Starbucks where do we go with it man I
like the Amazon thing wouldn't it take
place in an Amazon warehouse and [ __ ]
and everyone's trying to escape from a
zombies on those [ __ ] things they
ride around what are they called
what is it Segway the forklift Segway
we're like scooter yes I think if I was
gonna do one of those today I would do
it at like galaxies edge you know like
like some theme park installation
because that is at this point the purest
distillation of economic greed there is
which is they've already got you for the
hundred and fifty bucks it cost you to
walk to the door and then they're gonna
get you for the food that you buy me
ain't gonna go on the [ __ ] ride and
here's the mall you have to go into when
you get off the ride and you can't walk
past all that stuff with a nine-year-old
and not buy them everything they want
this episode of fat man Beyond sponsored
by Disney hey
but it doesn't have to be galaxy's edge
but some you know theme-park world that
somebody has built and maybe it's a
[ __ ] zombie world why isn't there
zombie theme park aside from like
Halloween haunted nights that happened
in theme parks I don't go cuz I'm a
[ __ ] but yeah that's that's what I do
where does Dawn of the Dead happen well
I mean based on my body of work I've
already done my mole movie so I can't go
there
you know I'm tempted to say convenience
store but I've been saying that for 25
years where does one go where did
weirder people pas where do people
Costco Walmart I mean it's - oh but you
know you're still do you do it about
consumers and like is that the statement
one makes at this point like what is in
nineteen in the 70s if that was your you
know we're gonna take on commercialism
consumerism what is it doctor Museum
selfie Museum yeah all the zombies would
be like
let's see what is where where comment on
I mean that's close to my heart and [ __ ]
just because you wouldn't know the
difference where would you say we're
kind of the dead are you dead or in your
inline-four Hall age if just shuffling
man I was in line at Hall H and I died
now come back to life let's wear
political party conference I'm tempted
to say yes but [ __ ] I'm tired of
politics like if I'm gonna watch a
zombie movie I don't want to [ __ ] talk
about that [ __ ] we're food hall or if
you do it about politics just have the
zombies win in the first 10 minutes and
then that's it cuz everybody's dead
great yeah it begins of like election
that everyone's like no this is the
worst thing that ever happened in that
bar like I take it back
the word is texting while driving it's a
very small movie the whole zombie movie
takes place in a car
Facebook Facebook man yes I got it
go Jurassic Park we've Dom bees with
Dinosaurs zombie dinosaur be [ __ ]
dinosaurs
nothing's gonna beat that give it up for
Java dinosaurs you win give it up for
Galen latest Germany may I also say
happy birthday to my boyfriend Nicholas
Gomez [ __ ] yeah what what's his name
Nicholas go man where is Nicolas Nicolas
I join her in the spotlight before we do
this are there any other birthdays today
or is there another birthday here who
yours stand up there and join them in
the spotlight
[Applause]
[Music]
anyone else celebrating a birthday good
here we go I smell a three-way a
three-way when were when were you born
[Music]
81 when were you born Nick all right so
he's got you by a couple of years and
stuff but born on the same yeah sit the
[ __ ] but born on you were born
technically you were born on his
birthday you were a gift to him he just
didn't know it until now here we go
everyone knows the words this give it up
for the boys ready in the count 3 1 2 3
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you happy birthday dear Eustis guys
happy birthday to you
[Applause]
kaylynn don't forget your stuff Kaitlyn
you win you get to take him to the
movies for his birthday welcome pleasure
alright JC give us another victim
looking for Chris Dorman grass give it
up for Chris man thanks guys how are you
Chris I'm doing fantastic thank you guys
so I had a question for you guys I think
everyone in this bar right now is very
very excited about the Masters of the
Universe show right
slide over so my question I'm a big
animation fan and a big voice over a fan
I understand that non-disclosure
agreements are a big part of the
industry so you can take the fifth if
you want to but I wanted to ask you both
what is your dream casting for the role
of Skeletor in Masters of the Universe
dream cast Kevin Smith is closing his
goddamn you're gonna get me fired man I
want to you can pass if you want to just
you leave your friend behind but after
you pass then you can't pass and then
you no friend of mine
I am [ __ ] I wanna I mean look even
though I could talk about who I want but
like that won't mean anything at the end
of the day how do we do this I mean I
have a suggest
let's hear your suggestion you suggest a
thing it was just on the Dark Crystal
series on Netflix it's the original
cock-knocker mr. mark [ __ ] Hamill
that would be astounding that is a great
idea that's a legit wonderful idea can
you get him I don't know please Kevin
he's very busy these days but what a
great idea [ __ ] that's true he's a
[ __ ] voice talent guy how do we do
this well I mean we could we could do
the spin where if we dream casted it it
can't be somebody who's alive
so we have Hoshi so we can then we'll
never get in trouble we can never get in
trouble nobody can like my agent said
that Kevin Smith wanted me to play bla
bla bla
that's right that's right oh my god
because I'm like I want Ben Franklin to
play he-man alright so Skeletor as a
dead man dead actor playing Skeletor on
the news Greg Langella is alive what
about
alright here's mine Robert Shaw who
played captain Quint in Jaws as the
voice of skeleton yeah yes in that world
my he-man mm-hmm Paul Newman really yeah
yeah yeah old blue eyes himself in in in
this dead in Carnation of this I go
Christopher Lee head Skeletor
whoo that's good not bad right it's
really good Charlton Heston Robert ii as
Skeletor man isn't he still alive
did Robert Stack died I think he passed
away did he yeah it's been gone for a
while oh you know would be awesome for
[ __ ] Skeletor yul brenner
[Music]
bring me the head of he-man
all right we should do the rest who
would be Teela
Farah Fawcett majors ooh
Eartha Kitt oh yeah perfect good Paul
yeah
man-at-arms Redd Foxx
I'm comin Eman Scatman Crothers oh [ __ ]
it's a good [ __ ] Paul man
let's get man Crothers like I could see
that that totally works you've got the
power your power shining yeah do you
like ice cream who else Orko okay hold
on
Paul [ __ ] Linda I swear holy [ __ ]
it's meant to be we should get married
Paul Lynn as the voice of lad me amazing
the voice for those were like Paul Lynn
he was the center square on Hollywood
Squares forever but he's the voice of
Templeton the rat mm-hmm so he'd be like
Eternia is a veritable smorgasbord oh
what a great poem that was a great
question that was fun
you win a poster and tickets give it up
for him ladies gum wisely so fun all
right who's gonna bring it home oh there
we go
dr. Eric green
give it a hug man Eric's ears are you
truly a doctor or medicine doctor or
doctor of Loki I have to make a [ __ ]
confession okay
I'm clearly not a doc [ __ ] I was about
to concur no I'm not
fair enough not to go there but my best
friend was your best friend was a doc
yes
Farren and he was the biggest [ __ ]
nerd I've ever met in my life and I
loved him when you say he was a doctor
he was a doctor and unfortunately he
passed away and I'm my wife and I are
actually we found him we we discovered
him when he died and young yeah yeah
yeah and anyway he loved you and my new
friends and my wife were sitting here
and we're like how great is this like
one to be alive but also if he were
alive being here tonight with you guys
would be one of the greatest experiences
of his life yeah doctor of what he was
event he was veterinarian we lost a
[ __ ] animal doctors lost an animal
doctor
now the story gets really sad man right
a human doctor whatever but he'll be my
[ __ ] saving puppies and kittens we
need that for sure
Danna but we made some new friends and
we're all going around asking questions
that if you had the ability to ask a
question my new friend from Denver
didn't want to ask a question because
which I thought was one of the coolest
things I've ever seen he didn't want to
ask a question hate to call you out
because he knew that someone in this
room if they had the opportunity to ask
you a question it would be one of the
great moments of their life so in that
spirit I wanted to ask question on
behalf of my friend dr. Eric creepy
which is this what is the greatest
question in the history of nerdom to be
asked okay so like I got quote from a
character you're the greatest greatest
question that we've been nerd to ever be
asked yeah like this is not that I'm not
pitching this but like know who is Luke
Skywalker's father like that kind of
question right because I know also
swingers
all right so hold on
so what oh my god
who said that stand up [ __ ]
stand up give that man applause
Wow
wow that is staggeringly wonderful who
shot first and everyone knows what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
know what I'm saying everybody in this
room is like oh I know and it wasn't
[ __ ] hot you know it's a burrito
I'm telling you that's a [ __ ] great
answer do you have a better answer than
that I haven't answered I don't think
it's better than okay fair enough go uh
what is the answer to life the universe
and everything I thought of that too
that's a good one too man you're right
it's not near lose no no no I realize
that it's it's a step down for sure yeah
[ __ ] that was good and while we're here
we'll take who else got one [ __ ] that's
even better man that may be the [ __ ] you
that that may be the best [ __ ]
question the best sci-fi question Wars
or chore Trek that really for a long
time that was the dividing line man
that's a great [ __ ] question my fans
like I know the answer Trek what was it
JC said Do Androids Dream of Electric
Sheep the title of course [ __ ] yes
that's a great Paul who said who is
darkman falling for Liam Neeson what's a
nubian nothing
personal favorite of mine what else god
this is fun what else
wait set go
fantastic [ __ ] question right there
belong to an entire generation who's
faster Superman or flash that's
excellent right now
1 2 3 top 3 [ __ ] answers you could
have just stopped at who applied you're
absolutely right that may be the number
one [ __ ] question it may go over
everything else who would win in a fight
and then you just put in whatever names
you want so that is a total sci-fi nerd
[ __ ] question that they still ask
today Jason Mewes I was just with them
today where you're interviewing but
being interviewed for the movie and when
we left we were walking someplace we saw
somebody had a Hulk tattoo and as we
[ __ ] walk down stairs he goes who do
you think would win in a fight the hawk
/ Hawkman and I said there is no Hawk
unless you're talking about Buck Rogers
and he goes no man the hawk
and I was like the hawk but you said
Hawk man he's like Hawkman versus the
hawk the hawk the incredible hawk I'm
like it's Hulk you [ __ ] idiot Hulk
[Laughter]
but who would win in a fight is
definitely [ __ ] that's part of our
world that's a big part of what fuels it
and probably what created fandom think
about the first [ __ ] ever got
together as cavemen and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
like talked about science fiction the
Eagle vs shark yes who would win in a
fight that's great man anybody else yes
more comment that a question
did the contractors on the Deathstar
deserve to die that was definitely my
question yeah I also like to be honest
nice I mean not science fiction I'll
take it
that's [ __ ] great but I'd say that's
a comedy question that's true that's
true man what house are you wow that's
good I would have never thought about
that that's a sad generation after us
House of to senator eighties genius that
was a great [ __ ] question give it up
for a man in honor of the great doc we
miss him man
pleasure pleasure you honored your
friend man that's beautiful [ __ ] we're
out of [ __ ] is that yours
I want reduce I don't know last shirt
who left a fly shirt that's like super
small is that meant to be sign oh well
done is that meant to be signed
is there no Marvel question well I mean
the who'd win in a fight absolutely what
superhero not announced for the MCU
would I like to see I think I mean yes I
would like to see no but I bet you we're
gonna get Nova sooner or later in a
world where they're just getting around
now to the ten rings which they've
referenced in the [ __ ] first Iron Man
like right now like we're gonna get
shang-chi and then the master and the
legend of the ten rings in that world I
could see them getting to Nova a couple
years from now you know where they've
set up the Nova Corps in guardians and
then we've forgotten about it so to
bring him back so they destroyed that
planet right Zend are they which he
destroyed which when they they didn't
come back they're all dead right even
though the [ __ ] snap and the double
snaps and our everyone that was killed
on Xandar
Maine's dead yeah so there's a nova like
there could be a nova still out there
and then they get to do nova that would
be great
I think that's come Adam warlock
absolutely and they tease that at the
end of guardians to remember she's like
I called him Adam who would I like to
see from the I mean it sounds like it's
coming but I really do want to see
Submariner man like I think that and it
sounds like it's gonna be in Black
Panthers we've heard and that's
fantastic
I look forward to seeing that character
come into the movies I mean we've seen
DC do the oceans and they did a great
job with Aquaman but like I want to see
what the Marvel oceans look like there's
a character I love from a miniseries
they did years ago called fool-killer
that I would love to see him do but I
can't imagine they'll ever get that far
down the bench slapstick Wow holy [ __ ] I
I kind of want Kraven the hunter yes I
agree
that'd be great Kraven the hunter men
and do that storyline to you know
fearful symmetry cinema which I thought
for a minute when like at the end of
which I rewatched far from home it's on
home video and [ __ ] the movies just such
a delight you smile throughout the whole
thing and then in the last two minutes
of the movie they're like here's an even
better [ __ ] movie credits and you're
like wow and I got so psyched and then I
got instantly sad cuz I'm like it's all
over well we're not gonna get what they
were gonna do unless those two [ __ ]
mega Giants get together again well you
can still have a Spider Man movie where
everybody knows his name I guess yeah I
guess you're right I mean it's just not
the you don't get happy anymore you
don't get him as his sort of cue in the
way that we had and far from home right
but you can still have oh [ __ ] my life
in shambles and everybody knows who I am
and I can't go to school anymore and I
can't go home anymore and
I'm a mass murderer and I'm on the lam
he's a lamis well that would mean that
would mean that who's playing gentlemen
Jamison JK JK Simmons is in three
spider-man universes Sam Raimi's
universe the Marvel Universe and now the
Sony standalone non Marvel Universe the
only guy to play @j jonah Jameson and
three universes he's the true Walker
between worlds he is and also
Commissioner Gordon yes also not my
tempo my tum oh my god he was so good in
that movie yeah when I went to one of
the meetings the the the pitch that I
had today the lobby of this particular
floor seems to be like the hitch pin
we're like all of the people who were
coming in to pitch their TV show I'll
have to wait together in this massive
Lobby and JK Simmons was part of one of
those other teams going in to pitch and
he's a frightening human being to sit
next to frightening he just like looks
because he's like 60 something years old
made of like corded wood like his arms
or just he got into it he's got guns
yeah like he got jacked for Commissioner
Gordon and somebody told them he thought
he was playing Batman he got real
[ __ ] jacked
he got to set they're like no you're
Commissioner Gordon when do I take my
shirt off I did all this work turn on
the light I'm gonna rip my shirt off
yeah and also like I go back to Oz with
him that's true
and if you've never seen eyes he was an
awful awful human being a tariff burns
Schillinger yeah and so to just see that
dude like in the wild is frightening I'm
a big law and order guy so when I see
him i see Skoda the guy who was like the
forensics dude though he was always
sarcastic and [ __ ] I love them loved
them in that role [ __ ] we're at a radish
oh man we're out of show we're out of
questions we're out of [ __ ] q and a's
I guess all that's left is to ask the
folks here do you have a good time
ladies yeah
I I had an absolutely [ __ ] wonderful
time man that [ __ ] QA questions are
great it was fun and [ __ ] and we got a
great discourse going man I'm gonna miss
this for a couple months when I go on
tour it's always my favorite part of the
week coming here man it's an easy
[ __ ] two hours and a pleasant one and
it's like being around [ __ ] friends
barely feels like a show it feels more
like a book club where we just sit
around and talk about [ __ ] and stuff
real sweet so I'm gonna miss it for a
few months but we'll be back before the
end of the year we'll do it like once or
twice more in December before the year
ends and stuff if you're looking for me
I'll be out on the road
reboot Roadshow com is where you can get
tickets October 15th and 17th feel like
I don't want to go see you and J with
the movie I just want to see the movie
you can go see it at any multiplex padam
events comm has your tickets and whatnot
this guy's gonna continue doing stuff
right here watch this space because he's
gonna be doing shows and stuff like that
and we might get you piping in here and
there from the road that's true I will
I'll be checking in from time to time
and whatnot
where'd you do my show yeah what's going
on here
but [ __ ] lays John it's like you know
it's tough - it's tough to end it
because it's like I know we don't get to
do it for a minute longer and stuff so
I'm stalling and I shouldn't I really
and the Lord of the Rings type [ __ ] yeah
and things can we do here from the
Eagles I can't thank you enough for
coming out and supporting the show as
you know from last week we had an
anniversary of sorts what if this is the
11th sell out straight JC or 12 10 10
this is a tenth straight sell out man
you guys sold us out
but there absolutely is no show without
the guy to my left give it up for mr.
Markman Arden come to the herbarium on
Friday and get some of our new Weed Man
James I'm Bob we're gonna sell you weed
right there man
failing that that's all we got man that
is fat man beyond for this week I'm
Kevin Smith I am mark Barnard tune in
next season yeah come back in a little
while same bat-time same bat-channel
spot cast calm or youtube.com slash
Kevin Smith for the good of all creel a
gentleman I
[Applause]
[Music]
you